what do you say when people ask you what
you
do I say that I'm am just a lowly
shampoo razor and chocolate
mle I've only been saying that for about
a week though yeah that's a a new a new
industry for you what what it is a
terrifying question when people ask you
what you do when you're an entrepreneur
because uh you never quite know what to
lead with and whatever you lead with
will be the box that people put you in
so I I I never to answer the question
very honestly when I was a teenager I
had I was the first person I knew with a
cell phone other than you know Bankers
who I didn't know but I was an I was an
early adopter of the of the flip phone
and my first voicemail I said I was
probably 17 and I said uh Jeremy boring
writer producer and Shameless
self-promoter ah very nice yeah I I I
feel that myself as well you know what
what what do you say about who you are
you know you what you do very largely
determines the way that people see you
and yeah if you've got a lot of
different things you're interested in
lots of different things that being said
the word entrepreneur is the most wanky
title that anybody could bestow on
themselves second only to thought leader
yeah well I I certainly never uh
identify myself as either of those two
things can you give me the origin story
of the daily wire from your perspective
I'd be very interested to hear this yeah
absolutely uh you know a long time ago a
boy loved a girl 1979 no the the real
truth is the daily wire it is one of
those kinds of stories so many sunry
paths that were all seemingly leading in
different directions brought us to this
moment where the daily wire was formed
you have Ben Shapiro who you know
wonderin child prodigy violinist who
wanted to be the first Jewish me member
of the Supreme Court who became the
youngest nationally syndicated columnist
as a teenager at his first bestselling
book as a teenager who you know Pro went
to Harvard Law and imagined a future for
himself working in law and then politics
but who found himself being the fastest
talker talking person in an industry
known for slow talking you've got me who
you know kind of the classic Go West
Young Man small town big aspirations guy
moves to Hollywood to be an actor and
sort of quickly encounters the reality
that he doesn't have what it takes to
succeed in in that business uh
for in phases came to that realization
um you have Caleb Robinson our
co-founder and Co CEO who you know very
got married very early had his first kid
as a teenager and his first business as
well as a as a teenager putting in docks
underwater in lakes and Texas like we
just all had this background that in no
way seemed like it was pointed toward
running a a major media company but you
know the the shorter window version of
it is that I met Ben Shapiro at a Coffee
Bean on ventur Boulevard in Studio City
and I recognized pretty quickly that Ben
was a once in a generation talent and a
lot of the things that people thought
were liabilities for example how quickly
he speaks I thought could be real assets
if deployed in the right areas and I was
in a low moment sort of in my Hollywood
aspiration my how old are you at this
point no I I think this probably 12
years ago 14 years ago something like
that yeah yeah so I was not young I was
30 but I saw something in Ben and I
thought it was worth taking a detour
taking a break from the things that I'd
been working on to help Ben and and Ben
saw something in me you know Ben wanted
to be in business and
he Prides himself on creating
opportunities for his friends and he
does a great job of that so Ben started
creating these tiny opportunities for me
to like make videos for the internet and
make a little money you know and when I
say a little money I mean like $5,000
kind of gigs you know and then I started
seeing opportunities for Ben to really
become prominent and started pursuing
those with with the influence that I had
at that time largely influence with
conservative wealthy people in Hollywood
who contributed to various 501c3 on the
right where I thought I could find
openings for Ben and and together we
just sort of helped each other along
this path toward
success I heard Ben talk about a time
where you were more front faing in terms
of talent and Ben was more operator in
terms of behind the scenes and then at
some point that seemed to flip a little
bit what's the what went on
there yeah well I think Ben may be
selling himself a little bit short there
you know he he was doing a lot of
front-facing work but he was a Harvard
trained attorney and when we met he was
General Counsel for a media company so
he was working more operationally in
those early days and I was just trying
to be you know a a writer and producer
within the Hollywood System so in that
sense perhaps I was a bit more
front-facing but the real thing that
happened was Pierce Morgan you know Ben
had a very famous encounter with Piers
Morgan over gun control uh in the wake
of of a terrible school shooting I
believe it was
Parkland and and Ben just brought all of
the things that make Ben Shapiro such a
special talent to bear in that interview
and and I realized in that moment you
know there was a real change happening
away from sort of
corporate brand media toward individual
influencer media I don't think we're
really using the term influencer at that
time but I at that time I called it
Talent based as opposed to company based
and I and I said to Ben you know we need
to make you famous the right way to
change the culture the right way to
impact the political conversation isn't
really through company forming right now
it's through uh personality forming so
so let's work together on that yeah
people don't follow things they follow
people you look at uh Cristiano Ronaldo
50 million followers Real Madrid 25
million followers Elon Musk 200 million
followers I don't know what Tesla or
SpaceX or anything else has but it's not
going to be as much people relate to to
people and there's something as well
kind of this ick that people have around
corporatism and the overly polished
Persona that is a pretend version of a
person uh someone said to me over the
other night they referred to it as
trying to speed hack authenticity or
growth hack authenticity and it's not
that's not really a thing like
authenticity is emergent it naturally
comes out of doing the thing so I
understand that one of the interesting
takeaways from that you know there may
be a lot of people listening who are in
business or content creation or whatever
who think well I can do the front-facing
stuff but I'm also not a bad operator
yeah what insights or advice have you
got for people who are ambiverts when it
comes to their uh behind the scenes in
front of the scenes skill
set well a lot of people become famous I
we live in a era where it's easier to
become famous than it's ever been before
but to actually have a career over time
in the in the whatever we want to call
it the influence space you know to to be
a voice that people trust to be someone
who people believe lives authentically
believes will tell them the truth
believe has something to say that's
worth listening to you actually have to
be one of those things I think that I
think one of the challenges that a lot
of emerging voices have right now is
they they do figure out how to use the
system to maximize their opportunity to
put together an audience in the short
term but if you if you have nothing to
offer if you have nothing to say you're
not going to succeed one thing I'm proud
of at the daily wire is just how
intelligent our hosts
are you sneeze when you lie and God knew
that is not that talented he's not that
smart uh no you know what I I'll
actually brag on Michael because I never
do when we gave Michael his first show
obviously an intelligent
guy but he felt outmatched and he
started reading and when I say reading I
mean Michael would read two books a
week and the two books weren't like the
40 or the 4 Hour Work Week you know they
were like he was reading philosophers
and he was reading uh you know Church
fathers and he was reading you know the
the Western Canon at a rate of two books
a week he had a full-time job working
for us and then a full-time job reading
and he maintained that pace for probably
four years so you can imagine just how
much over a hundred important Works a
year 400 important Works in his first
four years and that's why he has a voice
that's lasted for as long as he has it's
not just that he's a hot take guy it's
not just that he figured out you know H
how to ride whatever current cultural
wave there might be there's a business
aspect of that too which is you can make
a lot of money really quickly on the
internet but money doesn't stack very
well you know we we live in a moment
right now in particular where there's
almost no yield anywhere if I had
achieved the success that I've achieved
in the last four years financially four
years earlier I would own a huge real
estate portfolio it would all be cash
flowing I'd be championing the 1% Rule
and the 50% rule in a way we would go
but today those those things don't work
those systems don't work the market
doesn't work and so the only way that
you can actually have sustained
financial success is through not not
this is a loaded term but I'm going to
use it a little bit differently than
other people use it wealth creation and
people will say that owning real estate
Is wealth creation but it really isn't
it's growing wealth that you already
encounter perpetuation it's wealth
perpetuation wealth creation is is
finding Market opportunities and
creating value and that's harder than
having a hot take that gets a lot of
clicks on the internet so I think that
the voices who are going to be around a
decade from now are the voices who don't
Pander to Their audience who don't just
say exactly what they think people want
to hear who tell the truth as they see
it while also representing Their
audience authentically and and with
respect and to create real value
opportunities for that audience you know
you see it with a lot of companies who
are trying to release products now which
we also do the daily wire I don't know
exactly what it will be over time but I
think it's going to be the people who
are who are finding those opportunities
to create value that are going to
succeed long term tell you what's
interesting about that Michael story is
so few people in the world of content
creation as far as I can see or breedan
any industry that isn't sport or maybe
classical music treat their Pursuit like
an athlete does or like a professional
and this is something I came across a an
essay from a friend David Perell three
or four years ago and he said uh treat
yourself like an athlete was the title
of it now the actual in classic Twitter
style I didn't read the essay for 18
months but I loved what i' interpreted
the essay as the essay that he wrote
wasn't what I created in my own mind but
it really got me thinking I'd read
Steven pressfield's uh the war of Art
and then turning pro and I thought wow
like imagine what would happen if you
treat The Pursuit Of My Chosen career
which is podcasting like an athlete what
happens if I get a comedy coach and an
improv coach an addiction coach what
happens if I work out the different ways
that sleep or hydration or breath work
or cold exposure impact the way that I
feel and how quick my mind works what
happens if I start doing on all of these
different things because an athlete does
mindset training and they'll that's
right do preseason conditioning and
they'll run drills and they'll look at
game tape and they'll spend time with
people that have got growth mindset and
they'll be with this coach and that
coach and the other coach and they'll
think about hydration and nutrition and
supplementation all this stuff it's like
well you know if you say that this is
your thing why leave more capacity on
the table than fully going for it and
it's cool to hear you know someone like
Michael
that steps out and has is able to
discuss philosophical works but to
realize that there was a trajectory even
to that and I think that this is one of
the beautiful things and one of the
inspiring things about YouTube and this
more fourth wall breaking world that
we're a part of because it helps normal
people that haven't yet got there which
is what all every single person was at
the beginning of their Journey think oh
wow I can go back to episode one of
whatever the hell thing it is that I
love now and realize just how [__] it
was and maybe it's even [__] than
what I do on my first episode oh my God
like I could be you know so yeah I
really love that idea you know people
ask me sometimes when when are you going
to have a show and I jokingly say well
jokingly and not jokingly they're all my
shows but the truth is one reason I
don't have a show is because I know that
it takes work to be good at it and I
don't have it takes a lot of work to do
what I do and you can't do everything
there's a there's a
great there there's a line that I stole
from an episode of Star Trek or
something where the character says no
one can live all the lives that they
would choose no no one can live all the
lives that they desire a choice has to
be made and that's true there are a lot
of things we could be but you can only
be great at a handful of things and you
have to you have to make those choices
along the way so I I don't have a
full-time podcast not because I don't
have the opportunity I could launch a
podcast today and it would be within
some reason a TP podcast just because I
have the power of a a huge company
behind me that knows how exactly how to
do it exactly how to Market it
but I don't have something to say every
day that's not the world that I occupy I
occupy the world of creating the
opportunities for my hosts to be able to
thrive at what they do yeah you can have
anything you want but you can't have
everything you want that's exactly right
very difficult
realization uh one of my friends Alex
talks about you've seen The Matrix and
there's that sandbox tutorial where Neo
is being led by Morpheus through a busy
street and there's a woman in a red
dress and he's watching the woman in a
red dress and then he says Neo were you
watching me or the woman in the red
dress and the point is that um
attractive opportunities are distracting
even when you should be focused on other
things but one of the challenges that
you encounter as you begin to develop a
little bit more is it's not a
hypothetical 10 it's a thousand
hypothetical 1000s and your ability to
say no needs to continue to scale along
with your skill set and that is
something you know I'm really really
feeling at the moment the last 18 months
for me has been a pretty big change
pretty big step change in terms of a lot
of stuff and it's a skill set no one
teaches you no one teaches you how to
say no more effectively to things that
you would have begged to say yes to only
6 months ago and um that's I suppose
that's one of the there's definitely a
degree of Envy I have for some of the
guys that work under yourself um because
there is infrastructure and guidance and
um and just a little bit less figuring
out on your ownness uh which must be
nice and it probably help them to just
focus on making the content rather than
being in the engine room working out
whether or not this decision or that
decision is the right one to make
structurally yeah and you know you're
also dealing with at the point that you
are in your career right now you're
dealing with the three I I talk about
this a lot but the three most corrosive
elements that exist in the world Fame
wealth and power and you're beginning to
have a measure of each of those as your
channel grows and as your brand grows
and you know they're they're not to be
handled like lightly you know each each
one of them comes with a whole range of
Temptations one of The Temptations is to
try to protect the thing that you've
built and your
ability uh all the things that allowed
you to attain it start to seem like
liabilities when you start trying to
figure out how to preserve it and it's a
real challenge how so give give me an
example well for example it takes
risk-taking to create wealth but
preserving wealth tends to be pe
people's natural tendency is to become
more risk averse as they go because they
don't want to lose the thing that
they've made and so in time especially
in this kind of space you become almost
the opposite of what you were the very
the very thing that helped you to
succeed become something that you fear
will cause you to fail and all of that
is
because when you have something you want
to keep having it something to lose now
you have something to lose so I think
that it's it's incredibly difficult you
know I've spent a lot of time in my life
helping people who were at various
stages of a journey towards success and
you know I I didn't know that that was
going to be my life uh but really from
the time that I was 21 to today I've
I've been more Merlin than King arur you
know I've been the guy over the shoulder
of the guy many many times in in various
capacities but I I've seen them all go
through what I kind of consider the the
almost predictable patterns of success
there there are just things that
everyone goes through along that Journey
what are the what what are the uh most
common pitfalls that you
see you know one of them is
that convenience starts to become more
and more and more important to you and
understandably so because you know
inconveniences cost you time and mental
and emotional energy and you have less
and less of that to offer but the ne the
downside of that the positive is you
start maximizing your time over Target
you know the more time you spend folding
your laundry the less time that you're
spending reading the book and so Michael
noes has to make a choice in a limited
number of hours in the day do I spend it
folding laundry or do I spend it reading
the book he's going to get much more
value long term out of reading the book
so the inconvenience of folding the
laundry is something that he needs to
replace he needs someone else you know
better that he spend money paying
someone to do something that you could
go well anybody can fold their own
laundry what a stupid thing for someone
not to do and that's true but if if that
same hour could be spent accruing value
to yourself you should spend it acing
the value and the person whose job is to
fold laundry also benefits because
that's how they AC
value but the negative side of it is you
do reach a point where if your best
friend had a flat tire three blocks from
your house you would send a tow
truck and when you reach that stage of
avoiding being inconvenienced you've now
you've now accepted yourself out of kind
of common Humanity you see this with
successful people all the time they they
become on one hand more human
and on the other hand less human and the
goal is to become more without becoming
less not easy that's very interesting
you know there was uh the almanac of
Naval rant is a book written by my
friend Eric Jorgenson it came out about
five years ago I think it's the most
highlighted perw book on Kindle ever I
think that's the a record that it holds
it's very very dense very easy to read
but dense is in it was all aphorisms and
maxims pieced together into a narrative
and as soon as that book came out
everybody in my world started talking
about leverage right that was the sexy
word leverage through code leverage
through media leverage through Capital
leverage through Labor and um I I get it
I people Outsource busy people Outsource
things and they do other things
instead but there are certain things but
you can't Outsource your Humanity there
are certain things that you should keep
a hold of and there are certain things
even within the business that you should
keep a hold of as well so you you
mentioned before about this kind of
almost this
balance between content that gets plays
and avoiding audience capture or
avoiding just sort of tossing red meat
to the mob in a very predictable kind of
way and ensuring that the playing it
safe or uh just simply saying what
people want to hear is something that
you don't do I do think that this is a
criticism that gets lobbied lobbed an
awful lot toward the right because the
content by its nature tends to be a bit
more reactionary how do you think how do
you think about this this balance and
what what's your what's your Insight
around the reactionary right kind of
accusation yeah well the right is
reactionary there's no question it
always has been throughout all of of
History a healthy Society needs a
healthy left because you need a group of
people who are questioning the status
quo you need a group of people who are
creative and trying to create uh the
next thing in the future but you you
need to balance against that with a
healthy right a healthy conservatism I
would suggest that in a truly ascendent
culture a truly healthy culture uh
you're always going to have more more
people trying to hang on than you are
people trying to critique but you do
have to have people critiquing because
the status quo is flawed people are
flawed therefore the status quo is fa
flawed there are people who get left
behind in the in the systems that exist
you need people challenging those
systems
um and so it is the nature of the right
to say to the people who want to make
change hey hold on wait just a minute
and that's that's a perfectly good thing
where it becomes bad is in these is in a
system like ours today where the left
has become ascendant where the left has
cultural and political and economic
hemony across our culture in that
situation you have more people trying to
undermine the system than you have
trying to preserve the system and in
those moments the reactionary nature of
the right becomes you could say on one
hand it becomes more important and
that's true it's probably more important
than it's ever been on the other side
you could say it becomes almost
completely a deconstruction of its own
which is to say that at a certain point
the right isn't actually trying to
preserve the right has become
revolutionary and is trying to create
but what they're trying to create runs
the risk of being retrograde and and
that is incredibly that is the
incredibly difficult moment that we find
ourselves in uh on the right in the west
today that we are we are in the name of
conservatism we're we're not actually
trying to conserve at all we're trying
to build and truly there are some things
that need to be built there are
structures on the left now that need to
torn down but when the right becomes
revolutionary historically it usually
has somewhat dark implications because
the right is trying to is trying to
build something that
constrains a lot of the good that's done
by the left how do you how do you battle
the worst instincts of the left without
embracing the worst instincts of the
right and while America has done an
amazing job of that historically it's
very hard now because the right is in
truly defe feet across right all the all
of the most powerful institutions in the
country so how do you do it well part of
how you do it is with what I I call
lowercase R republicanism and that's in
opposition or or in contrast to populism
populism says you know give the people
what the people want but that isn't
really what populism believes I mean for
one in America and in the west generally
the people disagree really with the the
fundamental the core propositions of the
right we like to say in America we the
people on the right we like to say
they've they've lost touch with we the
people but the problem is they've
actually become the people you know
there are more of them they win every
popular uh presidential election every
popular national election and so it's
not it's not actually while populism
purports to uh give the people what they
want what it really means is to give a
certain group of people what they think
they want what republicanism lowercase R
says says is no our job is to represent
the values and interests of our audience
of our constituency but also to lead
them also to be a check against some of
their worst instincts Al also to point
out to them where sometimes what they
think they want isn't what they really
actually want in the moment no different
than any other group of people I mean I
often think that what I want is some ice
cream and that is true in the moment but
it's not what I actually want over time
it's not the thing that I actually want
to build and it's always been the case
that a healthy Society has to have
uh leadership that both responds and
represents the people but also to some
degree challenges the worst impulses of
the people now on the other side of that
you have tyranny so on one hand you have
the tyranny of the people populism and
on the other hand you have the tyranny
of the elite let's called that
authoritarianism and there's no perfect
way to say well what is the system that
balances between those two because
people aren't perfect and the world
isn't perfect but it is in its own messy
way I think lower casr republicanism
it's it's a dedication to the belief
that both things are possible and that
while there's tension between the two we
have to Endeavor to to find a way to
navigate that tension and so the the
daily wire challenges our audience but
we don't betray our audience that makes
us I think somewhat unique in the
space yeah what do you think the right
is getting wrong mostly at the
moment I think that the right
has in most cases the right has
accurately arrived at a uh diagnosis a
diagnosis of the
problem but quite often it's wrong in
its prescriptions and it's wrong in its
prescriptions for a variety of reasons
one because we're so beat up for so long
particularly since the ascendency of
Barack Obama in 2008 when the
instruments of government particularly
in America started being turned directly
against us and we were we were being
crushed deliberately crushed by the
system targeted and destroyed by the
system and that makes you less
thoughtful it makes you even more more
reactionary sometimes we're wrong just
because things aren't always the obvious
and so for example lots of people have
given me Financial advice in my life and
a lot of them are people I really look
up
to parents and grandparents and other
kinds of
mentors but none of them had any
money and so most of the advice that
I've got and I think this is true for
most people most of the wisdom that
we've got most of the advice we've
gotten about money is from people who
never had two cents to rub together and
so it turns out a lot of the things that
they say that seem almost axiomatic are
just false the one that I always like to
tell people is my parents told me
probably your parents told you money
doesn't grow on trees what a lie money
does grow on trees money is there just
to be created wealth and value are
actually created but most of our parents
were incredibly hardworking Blue Collar
people who worked for a wage and in
their life in their experience money
doesn't grow on entries money isn't
created it's earned and so that's the
best advice they can give us but it's
wrong advice and in in the final
analysis it's wrong advice and so I
think that a lot of the places where the
right goes wrong is when it when it
Embraces ideas that seem axiomatic but
that ultimately Aren't Enough the world
is complex the world is Fallen people
are messy answers are often nuanced and
then both left and right are often
looking for uh a prescription that can't
exist
and I would call that the ultimate
prescription and this is where we get
into real
isms so people you know at the worst
extreme you have anti-Semitism emerging
left and right in a major way right now
where people have rightly identified
that the elites uh in our in our society
have accumulated too much power unto
themselves they've betrayed uh the
people and we've become kind of
conspiratorial in our answer to that and
so we start looking for a way to destroy
the elites and we start trying to label
the elites and find commonality among
the elites and that leads us into things
like anti-Semitism or radical populism
which wants to which wants to overthrow
even the concept of Elites but of course
it wants to overthrow the concept of
Elites while ascending New
Elites the other place where I think
that the the right makes mistakes is
what I call cultism you know a cult
leader always wins your trust by telling
you something by telling you a forbidden
truth and it's just in the mind of a man
when someone points out to you that
you've been lied to and those blinders
are lifted and you see the light for the
first time your your first thought is
gratitude and amazement your second
thought should be skepticism about other
things that you believe and other people
who tell you things but it is in the
mind of a man instead that your second
instinct is to now believe anything else
that the person who just revealed you
the hidden truth tells you and in the
era of the internet internet where we
Ascend voices particularly on the right
on the basis of them speaking one
forbidden Truth uh
and and now we just can't now we just
believe anything that that person tells
us you see this with you see this with
actors like Andrew Tate or someone else
who do point out something that is true
and that we' have not really been
allowed to see and if we did see it we
weren't allowed to say it but then
people put all their trust in Andrew
tape because he revealed that truth to
them they don't realize that he's
leading them down a lot of really dark
paths and that I think that that's a
tendency that's really uh evident on the
right I mean that's a tendency left and
right but we're dealing with it much
more on the right today that's so that's
so interesting that
um saying something which many people
feel is true or say in the privacy of
their own homes no matter what side of
the political Spectrum they're
on gives uh a kind of cult leader type
Clairvoyance to the person like they're
speaking truth to power like they're
able to say the things and
then the temptation of that actor to to
then be like well you know they they
were interested in what I had to say
about the Middle East so why shouldn't
my
epidemiology be taken seriously why why
is it why shouldn't I weigh in on the
trans athletes in sports discussion well
but also also because of the corrosive
power of wealth Fame and money that when
people start giving us those things we
start looking for ways to hang on to it
or accumulate more of it we start
wielding it for for different reasons
than we start saying things for
different reasons than the reason we
said the first things that we said
that's something that anyone in the
position that you're in or the position
that I'm in has to really guard against
at all times are you saying things that
are true uh are you saying things
because you believe that the saying of
them is in service of the good and it's
and the audience needs to be aware when
they're listening to someone yes this
person revealed to you a a forbidden
truth but is what they're saying now
true and shouldn't it be the case that
when someone shows you you've been lied
to shouldn't your first instinct to be
be to say oh I am too trusting not oh I
should trust this new person to tell me
yeah it's a it's just a replacement for
the last God is a is a new God that
comes in yeah that's so that Dynamic is
so so very interesting how do you think
do do you guys have a a strategy
internally or do you speak to your
talent uh in a way to kind of help them
not get out over their skis to sure that
what they're talking about is within the
domain of competence that they
have yeah I mean it's tough when when
people talk for a living they often say
things before they've thoughtfully
considered them I think that we have a
far above
average I think we have a really good
batting average on this I think I should
say one of the great things that we have
in our company and you know you you said
that you have a certain kind of Envy for
some of our guys because of the business
infrastructure and I understand that we
provide a lot of of support for our team
in that but there is something that we
provide at a more human level and it it
really is
camaraderie that you know we really
do sit down and have a have a cigar I
don't really smoke cigars anymore
although I did just launch a great Cigar
Company called
Mayflower but I've basically stopped
smoking but we do sit down with cigars
or whiskey or uh sit down by the
fireplace or and have friendships and
talk about these things and challenge
each other and without the cameras on
all the time without the cameras on I
think the fundamental principle what
you're talking about here is if you're
doing something regardless of what it is
personal growth changing from one type
of thinking or group of friends or
industry or place that you live whatever
when you're moving from that to
something else there are going to be
pitfalls and temptations and uncertainty
and self-doubt and it's important to
have other people who are on that
journey and ideally a little bit further
ahead of you on that Journey so that you
can just fact check whether or not this
was true I always I me make this analogy
because I was an only child so it was
always team parent was always right
because there was two of them and only
one of me and I was never able to go to
someone else and say hey would you do
you think Dad was right when he said
that thing so I kind of just accept you
know you were talking about
axiomatically it's like it's just this
wave of it's like well no one else has
said that it's not have this sense that
it might not be right but I who am I to
say no they're the parents you're the
child right um and it's kind of a little
bit like that relationship with the
world you know his here I have this
sense that I might be right about
this some people in the world maybe most
people in the world seem to say that I'm
not but I I really feel this and without
someone that you can speak to ideally a
group of people that you can speak to go
no dude like trust yourself I I think
you're right here I think that you've
got I think there's some there there
that's super super important we're
smashing ideas into into other ideas
here all the time both publicly which is
our job but much much more importantly I
think privately which is where we where
I think our our hopefully our character
is going to be more formed by that
aspect of what we do does that mean that
we all come to the same conclusions on
say a political issue no but it
certainly means that we've explored our
political beliefs in a crucible and it
moral beliefs in even more of a crucible
what do you think that the left is
getting right is there something that
you wish the right would do more like
the left is are there any lessons that
you wish that you guys could take away
well absolutely I mean the left is
admirable uh especially the when the
left is healthy it's it's admirable and
its care for uh the people who are left
behind by the system the left is
admirable in its recognition that uh
that the greater good isn't the isn't
good for everyone uh the left is
creative in ways that the WR is
historically not creative um creating
things is a
fundamentally liberal
proposition and so one of the challenges
that we have and and we're trying to
answer it at the daily
wire is to be creatives for
conservatism that's why we're putting
out this movie lady Ballers it's why
we're putting out the pin dragon cycle
it's why we put out documentaries like
what is a woman it's why we sell razors
and chocolates we're we're constantly
trying to build you know we don't want
to just be critics of the culture we
want to be creators of the culture we
don't want to be critics of business we
want to be creative creators of business
we we don't want to just be voices we
want to be not just talkers but
doers and I think that there is some of
that of course on the right there's more
and more of it every day I'm not holding
us out as somehow the only people doing
it but there are precious few of us and
if we want I guess what I would say is
if if we want to build build the future
for the country uh we better get pretty
good at building and we better have a
future that people want to Aspire to
that people want to live in I think far
too often the right speaks in absolutes
that alienate people so here's a great
example the daily wire is you know if
there's one issue that every person at
the daily wire agrees about it's divorce
divorce is bad divorce destroys uh
Society divorce destroys children we
talk about it all the time and we talk
about it in in very uh um practical ways
the consequences of divorce the the
damage that divorce does to Children the
damage that divorce does to the soul but
there's a lot of divorced people out
there sometimes they hear us talk about
these things and they'll write into me
and they'll say you know cool I get it
divorce is bad but I did get a divorce
now what or cool I get it finishing High
School is a you know the Ben talks about
the sort of predictive ways of knowing
if you'll be a success in life cool
don't do drugs but I did cool don't get
arrested but I did cool don't get your
girlfriend pregnant but I did now what
do you now what and I think that the
right isn't always good at having an
answer to the now what because we're so
busy fighting for sort of even the idea
of foundational truth that we forget
that most people's lives have not neatly
adhered to that and most people aren't
starting they're not starting their
Journey with our ideas at the beginning
as clean slates they're starting at
having already lived in the messy world
that is the left's very good at that and
we're we're not particularly good yeah
it is it is alienating and it's also
very uninspiring to just be a Critic all
the time you know if all that you're
doing is being cynical or skeptical or
tearing down or whatever it might be
it's just not that inspiring you know
like it's cool and I
understand in some ways it's very easy
to rapidly gain an audience by
identifying Mutual distaste for an
outgroup rather than mutual love of an
ingroup this is one of my uh rubrics
that I use to judge whether or not a
content creator is um well-meaning or
not and acting in good faith is Their
audience bonded together over the mutual
love of an ingroup or the mutual hatred
of an outgroup because if it's
permanently outgroup outgroup outgroup
that's just a purity spiral by a
different name and you're going to get
shaved off the outside of it when you
don't do something that Concords with
whatever their particular worldview is
so you mentioned there obviously this
kind of intimate relationship between
media and culture and this is something
that you are increasingly trying to
contribute to how do you think about the
relationship between media and culture
well for sure well first I want to speak
to that Purity spiral you mentioned I
call it a purity death spiral whenever I
refer to it and I won't and I won't
abide being categorized in a way that I
can't live up to and so you know I think
that especially in the conservative well
I shouldn't say that because the left
has their own and perhaps even more
totalitarian versions of this but
they're just not tradition traditionally
ethic they're not built around
traditional
morality but it is certainly the case
that a big part of what we do on the
right a big part of what we do at the
daily wire is talk about morality and
moral ideals but foundational to my
belief about the world is that I have
not in any way ascended to a point of
moral idealism of moral ideal um you
know I'm I'm a human being I'm I'm chalk
full of flaws I wear I wear many of them
uh right out in the open and there's a
whole bunch more that people don't know
anything about and hopefully never do
right nobody nobody wants their heart to
be seen by anyone
else
um I make a point to never allow my
success to come from presenting myself
as the example of how a person is
supposed to live their lives morally and
I make a point of not putting out
content that I think panders to the
audience that only wants things that are
wholesome for example you know a lot of
my a lot of the fans of the daily wire
who I love the most are always mad at me
because when we put out a movie it isn't
wholesome well first of all I don't
think they actually want wholesome
movies I think that they all watch down
to Abby in the office and friends and
Marvel movies and they don't hold those
movies to any kind of standard they only
want to hold us to to a standard because
they don't they're not honest with
themselves uh most people aren't my
probably myself included you know people
don't know what they actually want they
know what they want to want they reveal
what they actually want through their
economic behavior and their clicks
clicks it clicks and cash is Cash yeah
that's right you know I know what people
really want because they watch it I know
that people don't you know there's
there's not
uh I think a movie like I can only
imagine is good and it does good in the
world I know that there are a lot fewer
people even on the right who actually
sit around talk about how great what I I
can only imagine is than they do
spending time talking about how good
Modern Family was right it's just it's
just the nature of it we we actually
want things that are different than what
we admit out loud that we want I say all
of that to say I refuse to put out
movies that Pander to my audience I will
only put out movies that I think are
great and that I think that hold up as
entertainment and that you know even if
they're not great they're on the road to
being great by which I mean we're
becoming better and better and better as
we go but what I don't want to be is
like uh you know with all respect to
companies like pureflix I am not Pure
Flix I'm not saying Purex Pure Flix is a
it's owned by Sony now it was started by
Michael Scott and David AR white and
they and they made Christian movies and
they they did a great job from a
business point of view they created
something really good they found a
market and efficiency and they answered
that market inefficiency but the pro the
problem with making your identity
Purity is what you just said eventually
since you are not pure because spoiler
alert no one is you will be destroyed by
that standard that you correct the
standard the standard that you hold
others too is the standard that you will
be judged by that's exactly right what I
would much rather do is hold up uh is
hold up things that are in ttention as I
said lowercase R republicanism involves
tension tension between representing and
never betraying your constituency but
also challenging and leading your
constituency away from their worst
impulses
similarly uh I think in in the realm of
art it's our job to uh represent our
audience but also give our audience the
truth of of what they actually want not
what they want to want and I think in
your in the daily wire our job is to
talk about moral and philosophical and
political ideals but just oppose that
with talking about Grace and what
opportunities exist that meet people
where they are that help them course
correct and steer the ship a little bit
better you know in the real world where
we've all made a ton of mistakes and are
only going to make more as we go
forward what did you learn during the
production of the new movie lady Ballers
what was uh in ightful or instructive or
revealing during the the process of that
either filming or or publication
yeah one of them is how afraid people
are to laugh now you know it's it's even
on the right people would not associate
themselves with the movie when we were
trying to make it and inviting our
friends to be a part of it because of
absolute fear these are people who will
speak out about the issue but they'll
only speak out about it in very very
serious tones and they'll all say oh
mockery is a huge weapon you know we the
left is so mockery and we're so bad at
it but then they don't actually want to
make any jokes and they don't want to
make jokes because they're afraid of the
audience and they're afraid of the
audience because they have set
themselves up in a relationship with the
audience that requires purity of them
and it requires Purity from them that
the audience themselves will not give as
I say you know an audience member who
will say you told an off-color joke in
lady baller so I'm not going to watch it
will then go home and watch reruns of
friends
what is that about well friends never
entered into the the Purity compact with
them and so I think we have to not enter
into the Purity compact with our
audience either we have to be much more
thoughtful so I was surprised at
people's sort of unwillingness to have a
laugh about these really sensitive there
was a um there was a a news story that I
saw maybe it wasn't a news story it
might have been like a Reddit thread or
something yeah that I think you guys had
used extras for a particular scene and
then did people walk out some people
didn't know that it was actually for the
daily wire and then that that got leaked
on Reddit yeah how was that pretty it
was pretty funny you know some guys uh
who came in to be extras stormed the
basketball court saying Ben Shapiro is a
Nazi which I think that they should look
up in Shapiro and then they should look
up Nazi I mean I think there were a lot
of problems with their assertion but you
know the argument that we didn't
disclose to the extras exactly what the
movie was about could be made by any
extra who was ever on any
movie that's that's not how that works
so it it hurt some it hurt some people's
feelings I suppose
but it's funny man I'm not notd in the
hurting people's feelings business I
guess it's interesting it's interesting
for me to think
about about what the future of
cultureculture Wars is it it feels to me
I don't know whether you'd agree with
this but I think a number of people made
this point and I I it seems right to me
that we're past Peak woke that Peak woke
was kind of Summer 2020 is back end of
then um MH and I wonder what comes next
what do you think this must be something
you think about strategically very very
closely I think that it is true that
Peak woke may have been the summer of
2020 it's it's true that the left uh has
suffered some cultural losses really for
the first time in my lifetime and
therefore you know conversely the r has
scored some cultural
victories but we're still losing in the
areas that matter the most I mean we're
still losing our freedom every day to
this
regulatory uh
bureaucracy that is essentially gained
ascended to almost absolute power in the
country me Congress doesn't legislate
anything to speak of so we we live in an
incredibly dangerous time and what what
I worry is that if we don't have
better leadership on the right we're
going to end up into a very European
style conflict between the worst aspects
of the left and the worst aspects of the
right and in that kind of a conflict
there's not really any winning for the
good guys in the short term uh I that's
the thing that I'm the most fearful of I
want to contribute to the existence of a
healthy American right because I believe
that a healthy American right is the
immune system that can clean up all the
problems s from wokeism on the one hand
to uh uh bureaucratic tyranny on the
other
to you know loss of national identity
all of it you know loss of economic
power and stagnation and inflation all
of that can be solved by having a
healthy right in this country and so you
know it's a real challenge it's a
challenge that understandably when
people get punched in the nose over and
over and over again they just want
somebody who will punch back yeah and
yeah but but what we need somebody who
has a I'm not trying to make this about
presidential politics I think it's far
bigger what we need as a movement is
leadership that teaches us both yes to
fight but also what to fight for to
fight for the right things and
that's that's tough when you've been
getting clobbered in the face for a
decade yeah yeah it's very it's very
strange to think about how people
respond and how they're seduced by
particular types of uh of talking points
I think I said this to Peterson he was
on the show a couple of weeks ago I
think in part the ascendancy of someone
like Andrew Tate can be laid at the feet
of Jordan's moving on from the
conversation to young men Jordan's moved
on he's doing these things with Ark he's
now thinking about God a lot more he's
got this new book we who wrestle with
God he's doing 12p part series on The
Daily wire about Genesis or the book of
Exodus or something else right like he's
he's moved on from that conversation and
um people will step into that vacuum
yeah and they will into that vacuum in
every different subset all the way down
you mentioned there again about kind of
been I've heard you talk I think it was
Megan with Megan Kelly about how
politics is dominated by old
people but content creation and the
movement of culture at least on the
ground at the moment from the way that I
see it it's dominated by young people
younger people certainly younger people
than the incumbent that typically would
have been The Gatekeepers with whatever
was going
on H what's the what's the future of
that look like how how can it be the
case that politics is still this like
old God and yet culture moving seems to
be a much younger more finger on the
pulse guard well sadly I think that
that's uh that's somewhat representative
of what Europe looked like before the
first world war that you had an elite
that had lost touch with the people an
elite that had accumulated too much
power unto itself the whole continent
was being run by people who were far out
of touch from a age and demographic
point of view you know people you had a
very very old leadership in Europe at
that time and young people felt left
behind and were and were in many ways
Left Behind the danger that we have now
listen there's enormous opportunity in
the Creator economy I mean you know 20
year olds can have a voice in a way that
W with no Gatekeepers and that that
there's a lot of good that will come
from that there's bad that comes with it
too one thing that you lose when you
lose The Gatekeepers is you lose any
filtering mechanism and any wi any sense
of wisdom young people don't have any
wisdom they have ideas
and uh and so in the tension between the
good that comes from that and the bad
that comes from it we have to find a way
to navigate toward the good and away
from the bad it's good that we have more
voices it's good that there aren't
Gatekeepers who can keep out
ideas um good ideas that they oppose the
negative is there's also no Gatekeepers
to keep out the bad ideas that we should
all oppose yeah and there's things that
can lyic hijack which are not worthy of
the attention that our brains want to
give them right that's exactly right I
about this a lot that technology is like
a technology represents a hardware
change and when Hardware changes
software has to change and we are not
developing the software fast enough to
deal with all the change that's happened
in the system uh In Our Lifetime you
know we haven't we've barely dealt with
the printing press and now we're trying
to deal with you know the internet and
Ai and uh and and you name it and so
many of our problems today it it may be
the case that all of our our problems
today in the west are just not yet
understanding what to do with the
internet and mass communication I think
Downstream from that is there's an awful
lot to be laid at the feet of it
Jonathan Heights just released his or
announced his new new book uh which is
coming out in March of next J I'm very
interested to speak to him about that
because so much of so much and there's
almost like an excuse that people can
just throw it's like it's social media
and Technology again I do think that it
gets both overused underused for things
people forget about it atically or like
the thermodynamics of the system and
then they use it as a scapegoat
Boogeyman to explain things which are
actually well no that's just agency or
sovereignty or individual Integrity that
someone hasn't decided to to deploy
here's one question I had for you who
who are some of your favorite content
creators outside of the guys that are at
DW because you must get delayed flights
you get stuck in airports and stuff you
got to watch something to distract you
who do you turn
to who do I listen to um you know I it's
funny I went through a big phase of
listening to Gary V and I was listening
to Gary Vee because Gary Vee is not like
me in any way I don't even understand
like fully one-third of the words that
come out of Gary vander's mouth I do not
know what they are it's some music
reference to genre that I don't know
some sports reference that I will never
understand it's something about wine
that I don't get he's he's from a
completely different world than I am but
he is always interesting he's always
challenging he's always pushing himself
he's always thinking and I get a kick
out of that because it's because I'm
it's not me it's not what I'm like I
like to listen to NPR offerings even
though I disagree with almost everything
all of their presumptions but there's
such a quality uh to their to their
approach that it always hooks me and it
inspires me to want to bring more
quality of that kind to the work that we
that we do uh of
late
um I've listened to it's funny to say I
listen to a lot of Jordan Peterson now
and I did not listen to Jordan Peterson
even six months ago to speak of I mean I
read his book and was familiar with him
knew he'd be a great asset to the Daily
wire but I I find myself more and more
listening to Jordan and the person who
we produce who I now listen to every
week uh even though I've been friends
with him and and been producing him for
a decade I've never listened routinely
to his show but I think Andrew claven
show is incredibly important I'm not
listening to it as the producer of it to
make notes on it I'm actually listening
to it because of the wisdom that it
contains and and the insights that he
has uh I've always loved uh Steven
Crowder I think that he's absolutely
hilarious I don't love him anymore uh I
have some fairly some fairly public
disagreement with Steven at the moment
but I still think that he's one of the
most talented funny guys out there and
especially in space no one there's not
that much that is funny so it's so
refreshing to to hear Steph's approach
in that regard I think Lyn Beck's the
greatest living broadcaster I think
Dennis Prager is one of the greatest uh
and and sort of in a weird way least
recognized in the age of the internet he
is very recognized in radio I think that
I think that if you just took the
library of things that Dennis has said
and started chopping them up for
Instagram he'd be one of the biggest
influencers in the world in very short
get the content get the content spun up
guys can I make a can I make a
suggestion for someone that I think you
should acquire I think that I think that
daily wi needs to put an offer on the
table and take Douglas Murray I think
that if you got Douglas Murray and used
the correct engine to make him
sufficiently media engine Savvy I think
that that could be Beyond huge I do I
agree with that
absolutely he's just I've been friends
with him for four years or so now every
time that I get to catch up with him uh
there's another level to something that
we talk about that I find particularly
interesting or particularly Charming I
don't agree with there tons and tons of
things that I don't agree with him on
but he
is something yeah and also I I really
think that we need to start
to add a little bit of the anglicized
British across into what it is that
you're talking about so I'm
team Murray for uh for you to bring
across the daily y I'll have him kick
back 10% to you if we make him an offer
fantastic uh where should people go
you've got this new lady Ballers thing
that's out now you've got pen Dragon
series p p Dragon cycle yeah yep that's
it uh that's coming out what else have
you got there's something else that you
announced recently Snow White we just
announced our new show with Adam Corolla
our first animated uh comedy series
called
burum
which I think people will really get a
kick out of it's It's Corolla and War
Patrick War Burton and Roseanne Bar and
tons of great comic comic actors voicing
these animated characters and it's a
real throwback to like Politically
Incorrect 9s
animated shows I mean I think I think
it'll be a real breath of fresh air for
people and we've got our bent key app
now which is not for not for the adults
but for kids it's a a separate entity
from daily wire for all the reasons but
something that we're very proud of and
that I think if we cultivate it well I
think it could be our actual Legacy in
the world because giving children a
place in this culture to actually be
children I think is is maybe the great
calling of of our time that's something
kind of strangely revolutionary and not
I haven't seen any of your children's
content yet um although I would be
interested to have a look at it it's
like it's so strange to just try and
make presumably children's content about
children's stuff that doesn't really
have have any crazy agenda that comes
along for the ride you know I it's
really really strange to
me that there isn't even more parents
pushing back does this thing in Idaho at
the moment uh and and uh penguin Random
House just yesterday announced that they
would be counter
suing the state of Idaho or something
know random story yeah dude I let me let
me pull this up really quickly for you
be embarrassing when you pull it up on
the daily wire ah how [__] penguin
Random House Sue Idaho let me see here
penguin random house and bestselling
authors Iowa Idaho this shows look I've
been a a 01 Visa recipient of your great
nation for two years and I don't know
the difference between Idaho and Iowa
penguin random house and bestselling
authors Sue Iowa over school book
Banning law the publishing D Giant and
four authors including John Green and
jod Pico joined several teachers a
student and the state's teachers union
in filing federal lawsuit the nation's
largest publisher and several
best-selling authors have filed Thursday
challenging iow was new law that bans
Public School libraries and classrooms
from having practically any book that
depicts sexual activity So Random House
uh they posted it on their Instagram
which was where I saw it yesterday and
um yeah I don't know that's their
position was we're pro First Amendment
we are this is like an imposition on the
world of publishing in some way um I
don't know the the first amendment is is
sacred
um kids don't have unlimited free speech
rights because they're kids the the idea
that you have the right to say anything
you want to a child was nowhere in the
imagination of the founders of this
country and the idea that we should be
arguing whether over whether or not it's
a violation of the rights of a publisher
to sell sexually explicit content to
kids is just proof that we've just
completely jumped the
shark as a society yeah go check out Ben
key it's a I'm very very proud of it we
have 18 shows there now a lot of it
licensed but four daily wire originals
and and of those four all four of which
I'm proud two of them are truly daily
wire Creations an animated show called
chip Chilla and a live action show
called Mabel mlay and I I think we have
the opportunity over time to build
something meaningful beautiful that is
not um you know it's not about partisan
politics it's about values it's about
imagination it's about wonder and
creativity and all the things that sort
of underg a society the things that
you're supposed to learn in the
childhood that you're supposed to
have Jeremy boring ladies and gentlemen
if people want to check out lady Ball's
the new movie Where should they go have
you got any codes is there codes
happening at the moment no codes at the
moment go to dailywire
plus.com and you have to be a subscriber
but I think we're running the biggest
discount on subscriptions that we'll
that we run all year right now as we
speak there it is Jeremy I appreciate
you thank you man thank you for the time
if you enjoyed that episode then press
here for a selection of the best clips
from the podcast over the last few weeks
and don't forget to subscribe